un atropellamiento a peatones en una de
las zonas comerciales más populares de
berlín a las diez y media de la mañana
hora local un hombre arroyo con su auto
a una multitud de transeúntes una
persona murió y la cifra de heridos
sigue en aumento el hombre pudo ser
detenido inmediatamente y actualmente se
encuentra bajo nuestra custodia ahora
estamos tratando de reconstruir el
crimen las autoridades aseguran que el
hombre puso de nuevo en marcha su
vehículo y se estrelló con el escaparate
de una tienda ubicada a unas cuadras más
adelante las investigaciones se enfocan
en determinar si se trató de un
accidente consecuencia de una emergencia
médica o si se trató de un acto
deliberado para reconstruir el suceso
estamos buscando obviamente si se trató
de un acto intencionado o de un
accidente de tráfico que pudo producirse
debido a una emergencia médica en este
momento estamos tratando de aclarar eso
el accidente ocurrió muy cerca de la
iglesia kaiser virgen uno de los
monumentos más conocidos en berlín la
policía de la capital alemana publicó en
twitter que el conductor es de origen
armenio de 29 años y reside berlín
alemania no es ajena a este tipo de
acontecimientos 13 personas murieron en
2016 tras un ataque contra el mercado
navideño de la capital y en 2019 una
camioneta mató a cuatro personas en
berlín después de que el conductor
sufriera un ataque de epilepsia